así
volando a ucrania y a rusia para liderar
las negociaciones pasando horas al
teléfono y preparando sanciones emanuel
macrón quien también ostenta la
presidencia rotativa del consejo de la
unión europea ha dedicado su agenda de
las últimas semanas a la crisis ruso
ucraniana un fuerte contraste con sus
rivales presidenciales que han estado
dedicados a hacer campaña a lo largo y
ancho del país francia votará en la
primera vuelta presidencial el 10 de
abril y los sondeos apuntan a una
victoria de macrón aunque el actual jefe
de estado todavía no ha oficializado su
candidatura tiene hasta el 4 de marzo
para hacerlo y según la agencia afp el
presidente ya ha planeado un primer
mitin al día siguiente el 5 de marzo en
marsella algunos politólogos justifican
la demora de macrón en entrar en la
carrera electoral por la posibilidad de
una guerra en ucrania y hay que
considerar que hay una crisis que
gestionar y que una vez se entra en
campaña todo el resto se detiene hay una
crisis y esta crisis ucraniana bloquea
un poco la situación la crisis del cob y
también bloquea la situación y cualquier
medida que se tomen se interpreta como
parte de la campaña
los candidatos consideran que todo forma
parte de una puesta en escena de macrón
según su equipo probablemente el actual
presidente no participará en ningún
debate antes de la primera vuelta
el presidente está huyendo del debate
democrático está huyendo del debate
democrático en parte porque no puede
encarar su mediocre balance en términos
ambientales y en prensa y redes sociales
también se habla de su estrategia de
comunicación en parte a raíz de las
poses reflexivas del mandatario en los
retratos que le hace la fotógrafa del
elíseo sin embargo algunos analistas
señalan que jugar un alto perfil
internacional puede favorecerlo en las
urnas